about 11 30 this morning we received the
911 call for approximately 28 people
trapped in the water at the Lockport
cave tour site they operate an
underground cave tour operation part of
that tour involves about a 300 foot
section
um where tourists or visitors rather
will get on a small boat
take them down a channel away within the
cave about 300 feet long and then they
come back return to where they boarded
the boat the boat can safely handle up
to 40 people there was 29 on it at the
time
somehow at the end of the cave or the
the destination that 300 feet section
there the boat became unbalanced and
capsized all 28 or 29 people were thrown
into the water
some were able to sell extricate by
walking down the water is walkable for
anybody that's right about the six foot
Mark there are some deeper areas of that
location and parts so roughly
um
16 people were rescued by fire and EMS
Personnel we have an inflatable boat
that we can launch virtually anywhere
through the use of compressed air we put
Rescuers on that boat to go down that
300 free Corridor and we were able to
bring back three or four people at a
time all together about 16 were rescued
via boat
everybody else was able to walk that
Corridor back to the original launch
spot
we also had a joint location where we
breached the wall from the outside of
the cave Tour on the canal side there is
an area that underwent some construction
years back portions of the wall are more
of a facade than a structural
bearing wall so we were able to breach
that with heavy equipment and rescue
some people that way unfortunately we
did have one fatality in the incident It
is believed for a time that he was
initially stuck underneath the capsized
boat and it did say take some time to
get him recovered and back to a safe
location unfortunately he had succumbed
to his injuries
uh Rescuers only received one minor
injury we had 11 people total taken to
area hospitals for minor injuries the
worst of which we believe is about a
broken arm
and a possible head injury but all other
survivors of the incident were were
relatively minor injuries we had upwards
of 10 or 11 Mutual Aid agencies from
across the county come in to assist us a
technical rescue team is in from the
county to help us with that wall breach
Niagara County dive team is notified
um to try to initially get to that last
victim
um I believe they may still be on site
now to try and recover that boat and get
some more data on what exactly happened
there but otherwise no Rescuers were
injured and it was relatively safe
operation uh once I got underway
took a minute to find the initial access
points where the victims were and what
exactly had occurred what resources we
would need Etc